welcome everyone i'm here with
um uh our esteemed guest today
uh gerald sussman and julie sussman and
chris hansen
and gerald sussman is a professor of uh
electrical engineering at mit and has
been for
a long time and his wife julie
famously also worked with him on the um
on the seminal work structure and
interpretation of computer programs
which was my introduction to computer
science
and chris hanson has also been teaching
at with gerry at
mit for a long time and has also been
working on the mitc
scheme system and lots of other things i
don't know chris very well so i look
forward to hearing more from you
um so will it mess up your recording if
we interrupt and make corrections so you
can no please
interrupt so chris does not teach with
jerry at mit chris lives in california
okay i did teach you good teachers right
but he's working at mit with me for 26
years
yes how's that as a system wizard yes
he system wizard basically i was the the
original designer and
still maintainer of mit scheme so right
yeah so so yeah my main question my main
two part question for you chris
is what is the best programming language
and why is it scheme oh geez
yes well the best programming language
for what that's right
i agree with a lot of different
languages i have written
many probably close to a million lines
of c
uh i have also written close to a
million lines of scheme
and i like them both for their well see
i didn't use to like these days i do
because the standardization effort has
really paid off and made it a much
easier language to use
um and scheme you know scheme is just
wonderful because it's so easy to write
in
you know useful and interesting programs
and make them
readable and that is that's a big deal
um you know
being able to write something that is
readable and is
very direct and has just the right
amount of abstraction is really a great
thing
um however since i'm uh
i'm commercially employed programmer i
program mostly in other languages
and lately i spent a bunch of time at
google writing java code
and more recently at a startup writing c
c plus plus code which is i really
didn't want to learn c
plus but i did learn it and it is usable
if you're extremely disciplined and
careful
but beyond that uh yeah so scheme is you
know
scheme is great because there's hardly
anything to it the right answer is that
it it's a language which does not have a
lot of ceremony
or you think about java you have to
basically bound scrape to the
author of the compiler well to get it to
work at all
okay it's like less than it used to be
but yeah it's a
it's a ceremony full language okay and
the scheme is exact
opposite it has essentially no ceremony
right
and that means if i want to express
something to tell students
how to do something how to think in this
style
okay it's easier to express an idea
in a very simple language than something
that's very complicated we have to start
thinking about the language too
so for the purposes of expression
something like
lisp in general and scheme in particular
is a winner
okay for if however you want to write a
device driver it ain't going to be there
you do that and see right right yeah
also there's that you know there's the
um the standard thing that people talk
about
with uh uh with other kinds of languages
is that you know the type safety and all
that stuff
and that is you know scheme is perfectly
type safe but it's at run time
and some of those type allocate type
declarations
although they're quite tedious can be
very helpful in organizing your mind
right when you're trying to build
something and trying to design it
you know you can sort of use the type
declarations as
a way of saying okay this is going to be
this kind of a thing
and so on and so forth and in scheme you
kind of have to keep all that in your
head
right it's like you you know how things
are going to work
but you know you can't write them down
in an easy way at least not yet and
that's one of the things that we've been
thinking about is how how you might
you know incrementally mix that kind of
declaration into a scheme program to
help basically to help document it and
make it clearer
but also to help you know the compiler
could look at it and say oh yeah so you
made a mistake here that kind of thing
too by using type inference and that
we talk a bit about it that in our book
even so
you know we talk about type inference we
talk about generating user types
um and how that stuff can help you write
programs that are
you know without getting in your way so
much but they can still help you find
you know find bugs in your programs and
that kind of thing so
you know that's one of the thing you
know jerry's right ceremony is important
but sometimes
these other things help too and there's
no reason why scheme can't do all of it
right it's just a matter of work the one
thing you don't want is i think
from the you know most languages require
you to do things
like put in the types okay it's a it's
it's not it's required to make it work
the nice thing about
again the list world is it works without
the saying that but if you say it it
gets better
okay and so the point is that again it's
a
it allows you to do anything you like
okay you can change the
meanings of the of the primitive
operators like plus i mean that's fine
in in in most lisps and scheme included
but the thing that you the thing that's
nice is that you
even though you can do that okay you're
not you're not requiring you're not
required to do anything
okay so it's sort of a libertarian
version
of programming okay
so in my uh in my day job i work i work
on closure with rachiki
so also spend a lot of time in this
space thinking about these same things
and as rich often says stop repressing
me
don't maybe say all that stuff i don't
want to say all this stuff if you want
to say it it's fine i just don't want to
say it
i like directly he's a really great guy
yeah that's exactly that's true
so uh why don't we go way back um
10 years ago i uh emailed you and asked
you if you were
interested in speaking at strangeloop uh
and you came out did a
fantastic talk um and it was a it was a
great experience and the your talk was
called we really don't know how to
compute and i went back and
and looked at some of that and it seems
like there are definite
sort of through lines from there up to
the book that you are
coming out with today it seems like it's
very much in line with that absolutely
the the the that talk
was a preview
of what chris and i were about to do
although we didn't know at the time we
were about to do it
we didn't know we were going to write a
vlog that was a little later but it was
it was in line with it was coming out of
the experience of teaching that class
right which we started for a completely
different reason but turned out to be
something very interesting
yeah we could show you the book you know
the book coverage sure
this is the uh that uh chris and i just
produced uh it's going to come out
from mit press was releasing it on the
ninth
of march okay amazingly enough unlike
i was really freaked out by that because
i expected that when they were the books
would be
in the warehouse we could just get them
they're already there
but unfortunately penguin random house
who's doing the distribution
actually doesn't release a book until a
date even though they have an
unboxing
and i need them because i want to give
them to my students now yeah
but it makes you feel very special like
a harry potter book you know it can't be
sold
i i've pre-ordered and i'm waiting for
my copy too so you know
well there it is uh it's full of lambdas
of course as you can see
for your you know amusement uh i can
shut that down again stop sharing um
yeah but it's it's
full of basically things that we learned
over the years and it's actually not
quite finished
that is that this is a there i've
already learned a lot
more since that book is finite we
finished this
version okay so that you know we can do
another
version of it in a few years and it'll
be better okay
i know exactly several places now where
i can improve it immensely
yes well and plus
to be really honest about it once we
invented a lot of the stuff
as we were doing it and we figured it
out and we wrote it down and
you know and so a lot of this stuff is
really just sketches of ideas
that you know we made them work but yeah
they're not you know the implementations
are just okay and they're not
uh you know they're not real in some
sense but
they could be made real and that's
something that i'd be excited about
doing
and jeremy i have talked about you know
how do we integrate integrate some of
this technology into mit scheme
so everybody can use it and that would
be really cool
yeah so it's sort of basically hot out
of the gray matter
yes
since it took us so many years to write
the thing
a book always takes five years yeah do
you have like a
can you give like a high level overview
of the topics
is that possible if you want to could we
talk about
the book the topics so yeah so we have
over the the main chapters we have a
thing on uh
we call it domain specific languages we
have
a book about a section
sorry a chapter on um
pattern matching we have a chapter on
uh what was it the the variations on an
arithmetic theme we called it america
basically
generic uh genericity and also about
um dominators and things like that so
that was
that was a lot of fun um and then
there's a chapter about
uh sort of advanced interpreter
techniques
for building languages that are like
scheme but different slightly
so you know more flexible more more
something or other basically
um and then you know finally we ended up
with a
we had a very short chapter about this
thing called layering
which we talked about layering um both
procedures and data so that you could do
computations in parallel and basically
add layers to an existing program to
enhance it like adding units or
dependencies or
what have you to make the to add
uh functionality to the to the program
and then one of my undergraduates is now
telling me how to do it better
yes he's thinking thinking hard about
fixing some of the
misdesigns that we did and uh
uh uh also the propagation thing which
really
was you know it's sort of a vehicle for
thinking about fine-grained
parallelism but it also was you know we
we fell into this idea about how to do
optimal dependency directed backtracking
which as far as we know no one has ever
done before
so that was what we mean by optimal
that's complicated but you know we do
explain it in the book
but it's it's more like what used to be
called data flow machines
so and it's really not taking big
programs and
so much as starting from the background
up and also we built it at one point we
built a compiler from scheme to
down to these little engines that was
kind of fun too
so i want to resurrect that one of these
days
so it seems like jerry that you've all
you've used a lot of biological
metaphors and things that i've
i've seen do you think there's any uh
that that were anywhere
within sight of making things as
resilient as biological systems
no we have we we're still in the
dark about this look the most remarkable
thing it's truly remarkable
your genome is a gigabyte okay
it's everything it takes to build you
out of a single cell
plus it it's uh you know it runs you
okay it's it's a program that runs every
cell
and it manages to also defend you
against other guys who want to eat you
and you last about 70 years that's
amazing
and for you know it's pretty good well
furthermore it's super flexible you
change a little bit and you get a rabbit
instead
okay that's it's only a little change
most of it's the same
been been introduced to some scary new
attack vectors in the last year but
yeah maybe not maybe not new at all but
more just more visible than 100 years
ago too yeah
yeah but we're but it still works
amazingly well yeah
this you know so i think superfly it's
super dense
yeah only a gigabyte yeah i'm super
flexible how do you do that
i was gonna ask um it seems like a lot
of things i've seen in the uh
software design for flexibility uh and
the things that i've seen about it
online
are about making operations generic and
extensible and i was you mentioned data
in there i was wondering
like how you what your thoughts are on
the importance of
data and making how we make data
extensible
in the same kind of way
well that goes back to this layering
idea mostly although i mean
part of it you know part of it is an old
story which is
the bundling of data and programmed
together
which you know things like closures and
uh objects and
oop languages and that kind of thing so
part of it is just merging the data into
the program um but part of it the
layering thing sort of takes it in
another direction
so instead of having uh it allows us to
basically
and so the [ __ ] the primary thing we're
trying to
talk about is how you can take an
existing program
and adapt it without rewriting it
and so layering actually plays an
important part in that because if you're
going to do
if you know like for example let's say
you want to keep you know
keep track of how your computation is
running
and you know like let's say you want to
understand you know why something
happened you could add a dependency
layer or a justification layer or some
sort of
thing that would support explanations of
why your program ran a certain way and
you can do that without changing the
original program just by
as long as you architect it in the first
place to support layers
or at least you know it's easy to back
port you know to still run it with
layers added
which we know how to do now um and that
basically that that has some
nice effects because then you can
enhance your programs
and you know add these you know like i
said units dependencies any of those
things
that are related to the data you're
computing with
but not actually directly you know
in the main computation so it's like
it's like metadata basically right in
fact the thing is every piece of data
and every procedure has its own metadata
and procedures
yes and then potentially you can add to
them dynamically
yes that's and that therefore when you
execute some piece of
code you execute the meta code as well
and the meta code has to
has to uh correctly indirect interact
with the base code
we have a quite weak so it which is nice
because you know the the
ace code doesn't know anything about the
meta metadata code
and the metadata code only knows a
little bit about the base code like
you know for example if you're doing
arithmetic you want to do you know treat
zeros especially in many cases that kind
of thing
they'll affect the metadata um we have a
metadata system enclosure like this that
that
does some of that you can't use it for
everything so
that's the that's the caveat there you
can't use it for numbers but
you can use it for collections and
things like that it's a hard problem
and i think that we have talked a little
bit in the book about
one way of approaching it but i think
you know as as jerry said
his one of his students is trying to
clean that up i think there's still a
lot of more work to do there i mean some
of the problems we put in the book were
i see you recall there was one where
we're talking about you know instead of
doing the metadata just on the low level
operations what if you wanted to raise
it up to the next level
and do it at that level and that you
know and not do it at the lower level
and how would you go about doing that
and
i don't actually know the answer to that
i'm not sure jerry does either
but it's something that is interesting
to think about and would be
fun to work on so
yeah but the the the ultimate goal here
is to make it so
for example in the in the propagator
system that you've seen
we've talked about even
[Music]
at strange loop okay there was a there
was a certain metadata that's carried
along which is the
dependencies okay but that was done
explicitly in the propagator system
now we don't do that now we build the
metadata on the
on the primitive objects of the language
like
addition and multiplication and things
like that and that is automatically
inherited
in the point we pull it to the
propagator thing the propagator thing is
built on
on layered data so it can be
it doesn't have to be it isn't the way
we did it actually yeah
so that's an example
we've separated those ideas out for
example you could add other
other layer to the same stuff and also
the propagator is doing it the right
thing too
right okay well i look forward to
reading about it
it does seem like i mean i think we've
we've done some
some related kinds of things in in
closure so i'm really interested to see
how it
how that's different than sure um than
what we've built and
amazing things i've just heard is that
uh there's a gentleman uh
sam ritchie who's been writing writing
the s-i-c-m
stuff enclosure and it's working well
i have seen him a talk by him about it
it's very interesting
we've been talking about because there's
a there's some complicated
funny cases it turns out in automatic
differentiation
which the theorems even by manches et
cetera
you know with siskind and uh pro mudder
and uh
and radul that stuff doesn't quite cover
it
clearly and so so we've been talking
about that and of course we have the
same problems as they do
in our version of this but they don't
matter for
any real case that i know of i've
actually put in a
warning in my uh schematiles code for
for checking for it and made running all
the old cases including all the ones
that
jack has used for jack wisdom has used
for research and made sure that never
this never comes up
but in any case the um that really fixes
a lot of interesting things it means
that we we have a lot to
study there it's clearly not well it's
fully understood yet
i mean we we basically put in fixes to
the differentiation stuff until we ran
out of time
there's probably been more since then
there was one there was one more that
came through
last july right and i suspect there will
be more in the future as well
well that's great i also wanted to ask
while i had you on the phone um
jerry and julie i know you came out for
the eclipse in
2017 to the st louis area and
uh i was wondering if you had any any
good stories from
coming out i was fortunate enough that
my house was in the path of totality so
i just went out in the backyard
you see it because of where you lived
and we did not get to see it because of
where we traveled to
so we did not see the eclipse we were
completely only the few people they
clouded out
it was a long story and it's not worth
telling but we
did however we did have a short
visit to uh some things around st louis
that was very nice we got a
chance on our first trip when we were at
strange
uh strange loop in 2011 we
visited the missouri botanic garden
which is
one of the really fine botanic gardens
but there's a
separate part of it out of town why
can't i think of it the name of it right
now it's uh shaw
is the shaw park park i think
we uh we happen to know the brother of
um one of the main people there and so
we went over there and he gave us a
private tour of some of it and
so we saw some really nice that's a
beautiful part do you see any bluebirds
i don't even remember know exactly what
we saw but they're rampant over there
an extra day in st louis on that trip
after the eclipse and we visited the zoo
which is really one of the
fine zoos um so we've we've seen some of
what
you have to offer out there well i wish
you'd just come over to my house when
during the eclipse we could
you could have just hung out in my
backyard
if we had planned that that would have
been nice
well there's another one coming up in a
few years you can stop by 24.
the real good one and the right place to
be is austin texas
oh good it's coming near here i think
out a little easier no but the center
is going to be in austin texas which is
also drier place that's true
less likely to be cloudy less likely
just
unluckily got in the wrong place at the
wrong time
or whatever sorry to hear that
all right well i'm going to wrap up now
and look at unless you have anything
else you want to share or want to talk
about
well nothing in particular except that
i'd very much like to come by again and
visit you again and then
uh strangely like a fun thing but we
can't do it right now while
uh everybody's uh worrying about this
strange viral disease
yes well alex is being an optimist and
planning in case you can have it so
i hope it works out um i guess i would
just say that going to your conferences
has been a lot of and
related ones has been a lot of fun
really going to
strangeloop was uh your first experience
jerry i think of of meeting people in
that community
that's right um and that was very
interesting and a lot of fun great
people
well i i had lots of great stories from
people telling me that they got to meet
you and had a great time talking to you
and
and it was funny because i had because
the guy steele had been out to strangely
the year prior to that
and for months afterwards people would
tell me stories similar stories like
that they'd been out to lunch with guy
for he's such a generous
guy as well and so um yeah and so that's
what
you invite strange loop he didn't know
who's alex miller or what stranger
knows it's for real is this worthwhile
so he looked saw a guy had been a
speaker called guy
said should i do this and guys said yes
okay so that's why i did it that's why i
showed up after all guys an old buddy of
mine
and then as a result of that going to
lambda jam in chicago and
closure sink by eric normand oh right
yeah
yes all those places well chris i would
love to have you out sometime as well
well when things are a little more
normal yes
yeah so when when you invited us to st
louis i was actually very excited
because we've traveled a fair amount i
mean not as much as some people
and we've flown across the country many
times going to california usually also
colorado some other places
and i know the mississippi you know i
might take a little nap on the plane
look at my watch oh
10 minutes till the mississippi there it
is you know it's exciting
to see but i've never been on the ground
near the mississippi
i've never been on the ground in that
middle of the country that i fly over
anywhere in the middle
so that was kind of special and then
chicago i remember i was very excited
about the chicago trip and i was telling
people
you know we've just been on a trip to
india and singapore on australia
i've been to china i've been to japan
i've been to chile i've been to europe
but i've never been to chicago this is
so exciting
and i wasn't kidding it's really you
know
it's a great town i miss what's in our
own backyard there you know and there's
something
sure we are now more well traveled
because of you thank you
okay well thank you very much good to
see you alex good luck with your
planning alex i'll be impressed thanks
so much
well i think we'll definitely do
something if you do it just might be
different
okay thanks a lot bye
you